hello and welcome to this video Jimmy
flume I think that's an i am right yeah
will be shoulder yeah but ok now he's
playing I wonder i can actually almost
pre-move c5 i go for my bank obey strap
at one the only move at is not that
great as a science 93 okay let's see
what mr. Schultz is up to Queen B 6 is
designed to amongst others be ready to
capture with the Queen on f6 and it
helps to support the Queen side a little
bit a5 now is an interesting look after
which Queen d6 is cool so what is he
doing here he well d5 Hanks I just don't
know if I should take it and it could be
rather dangerous business but you know I
mean if you want to live safely you can
play the Queens gambit declined so I'm
taking the pawn I mean it's a d5 bond
it's not just an unimportant pond and
one thing is it's not so easy for him
now to go if or maybe he still should do
it just throw a throw caution to the
winds well here bishop a6 even it's an
interesting move yeah let's do it
really i thought Knight b6 would be
pretty annoying now I mean okay
okay be three but that doesn't look all
that great
and while nite nite f.2d too i play d5
and wide resins so I bet this is the
thread anyway haha it took me a moment
to realize that actually d 5 or you see
I am he might cancel long after d5 right
because it's made on the aid well that's
that's too bad
the average night any of that a knight
c6 he might eat okay so let me let me
take on see form I just wonder how with
the bishop or with the night okay we can
go for the night
okay well I don't really mind it ending
here I'm a pawn up already okay I don't
want to take this looks a little bit
strange to correct his pawn structure ok
it's attacking c5 I just saw a large me
you set a problem really
hmm yeah I wonder what the clean is the
way here to players okay he's not
threatening to take on safavi I can
always play Quint eggsy form so maybe
just this I took far too long for this
simple decision but ok position is still
reasonably simple to play
yeah after Twilight resign okay yeah
well not much it's not fun now to play
this position with wide you don't really
have to resign but it feels like a
little bit of a train wreck I'm sure
maybe he just landed the porn way took
it took 14 seconds I don't know and i'm
also not totally sure about things here
so this this okay i don't think that
this is any good to be honest of it
maybeee form does this could be i mean
at least he's got some very serious
development here i will go back and I
don't know develop now it's a center
pond center porn is quite something but
why also has like 310 beam oops I didn't
want to do that that didn't want to do
either yeah probably like this attack
this bishop and I don't know now eat six
or something like that
he definitely has some compensation for
the poem I mean absolutely the engine
gives this position as roughly equal
after yeah well no not at a substantial
depth but this is kind of interesting
but now I think I don't think this is
enough because you cannot easily play
your form as I said maybe you should do
that simply um check he had to get to
get more tempe i mean i will take of
course and now it should be too i think
i have this actually this is a bit bit
of an annoyance yeah now that it's
that's no good the engine controls that
this has to be played and if i get to
get this end no I'm just to point up
that that's not enough and it's 22
center points you have it here and also
looks pretty awful yeah first I wanted
to blunder d5 but after castle this is
not all that clear okay well this is
actually clear what the engine gives but
I didn't see that this is not a bad
decision yeah and he cannot really take
here as I exception if one took me a
long time to see that and then yeah what
probably he should do is maybe castles
long get this this D foul play John yeah
when me you can continue here it's not
it looks awful but it's not like it's
losing immediately if I play this for
example greene takes I don't know add
that it's really a recommend something
something like that for example
looks pretty bad I moved you three okay
the engine wants to do this just to
prepare it I mean is king is not really
really all that great an interesting
variation actually with nie bede to them
to give up the pawn this is definitely
quite interesting if he plays you form
yeah interesting that that should be
compensation for for real ok guys thanks
for watching